When would I want to run other programs on my P220 so this is the atelier Robin right and you can say the same thing on
The true right so when would you want to run other programs out of your right?
Anytime you want to if you have other cold morbidities
Let's say a person's you know hurt their knee so they want to run accelerating healing and they want to put that by down by their knee
You don't want to add that to your night program. Just do that during the day that you get a chance here right before you go to bed or something
I
Have a cold. I feel really sick
I just really feel like I'm coming down with somebody you could do the overnight cold and flu program today and skip your cancer program
Of course that depends on if your cancer is raging. We don't want you to not suffer from a cold
So let your cancer grow
You have to use your common sense in that you can run other programs on your right anytime
I did pull up this slide that goes along with this question
This is what the P220's
Program looks like. This is what the atelier Robin's program looks like
Everything is in a file that says Dr. Cutters alphabetical ARR. That's my alphabetical list file
Well, these things are folders
This thing right here that you see it my cursor and then this thing is a file. These are all Microsoft icons Microsoft came up with these icons
Backward Windows came up. This looks like a little bit of a folder. This looks like a piece of paper. So that's a file
This is a file and these are these are programs themselves. This is just that
This is just a piece of paper in the file. So if you clicked on the orders manual, which
Don't click on that but you do get all the orders values with it
If you click on my special sets, click on that there may be some programs that you want to run that are dealing with your current
Comorbidity that you might want to run and then I have a file of Dr. Cutters 11th harmonic pathogen kill programs
Exactly what it says says there's probably about 30 programs in there that are specific pathogen most common pathogen kill cold and flu
I have a certain virus. I have a, you know,
Borrelia infection. I have there certain infections are in there different
Parasites and different things like that that are just listed in that file that you can run that are 11th harmonic and then it's got all the alphabetical programs that I wrote all these programs I wrote
And the ones that are that are
The ones are all of them are written in the 11th harmonic if it's appropriate. So they are that's what you
Could run any of those programs now what I did it put on here, which would be on top because I just took this screenshot of my
Picture yesterday when I put this this together would be your file a your name with the data on it would be on top above this
So that's what your folder would look like and you could click on any of these and run any of these programs and you could scroll through the alphabetical list
And run any of these programs now the true right everybody it's listening to me has had their true right for a long time so
They already know how to get through their programs and moving and move around in the program itself
But that's how a Microsoft program looks
And that's how you maneuver through that program certainly you could run any programs that you want
But you definitely want to be ready your answer program
If you know your cancer is still active